[Captions by Y Translator]
Let's take a look at how to
build your very own floating faucet.
A cool optical illusion that makes
it look like a faucet head is
floating on a stream of water.
[Music]
We got a common request
from Menachem Roubini,
and I'm almost certainly
pronouncing that incorrectly,
but it was asking if we could
please make a magic/floating faucet.
Yes, we can, and we're
going to show you how to do it.
Here's what I was thinking.
A clear plastic tube will lead
from a small pump up to our faucet above.
The water flowing down out of
the faucet should cover the tube,
giving the illusion that the water
itself is holding the faucet up.
To get started, we're going to need
a small submersible water pump,
a spigot or faucet.
I prefer the kind of looks
like it's a garden hose attachment.
Some 1/2 inch outer diameter clear tube.
This is rigid tube, not flexible vinyl.
This one's acrylic.
You might be able to find it
in polycarbonate as well, and a bucket,
or any other waterproof
container that's about the right
size and shape, and matches the look
that you want for your fountain.
And my bucket is also full of
these clear glass beads,
and I'm using these
because I like the look of it.
There's other things you can use.
If you want to use just
natural rocks, you can do that.
It looks good in all sorts
of different colors.
I do have a reason I'm using the
clear glass, and I'll get to that later.
But there's lots of options
like I was saying.
Our pump is going to end up
going down inside of this bucket,
but we don't want our cord
coming up over the edge.
So, like we did with
our small Vortex Fountain,
we're going to drill
a small hole into the bucket.
We're going to cut our chord,
and then solder it back together
once we've run it through the bucket.
For this chord, we're going to
solder one of the sides together,
but the other side, were going to
leave unattached because we want to add
an inline switch that lets us
turn the pump on and off
without unplugging it.
[Music]
Now, let's trim off the extra
cord so it gets divided.
This little piece of plastic is
designed to keep the two pieces separate.
This other side that we poke on top
of that has prongs on both sides,
and these are designed to stab
through the rubber of the cord,
and make a connection
between the two sides.
[Music]
Now, we've got our pump
inside of our bucket,
the cord comes out to the outside,
and eventually, we are going
to stop that hole up entirely.
We're going to use some hot glue for that.
But it's not time to do that quite
yet, because we don't want to
limit the movement on the pump.
So, let's grab our 1/2 inch
outer diameter acrylic tube,
and let's figure out the length that we need.
The faucets going to be
somewhere up here.
We can fit this down.
Now, the pump I'm using,
it actually fits perfectly over the nozzle
that comes with the pump.
It kind of snaps into place even.
It's a watertight seal.
It's just what we're looking for.
So we have to figure out how
high we want our spigot to go.
I mean, if we put it up too high,
then the pumps not going to have
enough power to really get
the water all the way up there.
If we put it too low, it's not
really going to look very cool.
So we're just going for a
few inches above the bucket.
[Music]
Now, we're going to use a
hacksaw to carefully cut that off.
Our tube cut, but acrylic is pretty
fragile stuff, and right at the end,
it did crack just a little bit.
We're going to use a belt
sander just smooth that off.
Give us a nice clean edge that
doesn't have any ridges in it like that.
[Music]
There's the edge of the tube, and we're
going to want to glue that right
down into the middle of the spigot.
But once we've glued it down, it's going
to be sealing off a lot of the opening,
and we want water to be
able to come out of the top,
and sort of pour back down, like
it was coming out of the spigot itself.
So what we need to do now is drill
some small holes in the top of the tube.
We've got quite a small drill bit here,
and we're now going to drill
eight holes into the top of this tube,
and we're going to try and make
it really close to the top.
Maybe only an eighth of an inch away.
Of course, since we do want all the holes
spaced evenly directly
across from each other,
we're going to drill right down
through one side, and then out the other.
[Music]
Running a little bit of sandpaper
over the top helps remove any burrs,
and it roughs up the plastic just
a little bit to help the glue bond to it.
Now, we need to attach
this onto our faucet,
and to do that, we're going
to be using some two-part epoxy.
This is J-B Weld, the Kwik version
of it that takes five to six minutes
to cure, instead of four or five hours.
You don't have to use this kind of glue.
Other strong types of glue
should work as well.
But I like this stuff because it is
designed to bond really well to metal.
[Music]
We want glue to get about as high as it
can get without reaching the holes.
That will help it grip a lot better.
[Music]
The epoxy's cured,
which means the faucet is now
holding itself onto the acrylic tube
without any assistance.
It doesn't fall off.
Not really wiggling.
Just what we want.
So now, we need to attach
this onto our pump,
and as I was saying before,
this size of acrylic tube, this is
1/2 inch outer diameter tube,
actually fits just perfectly
onto the nozzle that came
with this particular pump,
which is pretty convenient.
Now, I'm holding the pump, but I'm not
touching the tube or the faucet itself.
And as you can see, it
stays up right where we wanted.
One other thing that we want to do
before we add all of our stones back in
is I have this battery
powered waterproof LED light.
This thing's pretty nifty,
it's controlled by remote control,
and you can just change the colors.
It's not going to be hurt
by being underwater,
and it is battery powered so you don't
need any sort of cord running to it.
We're actually going to take this light
and put it underneath our pump,
so it's just resting
on the bottom of our bucket,
and the pump is going to sit on top of it.
Now that we have that there,
we can see how much of our cord
we need for to be able to reach.
So at this point,
we can take some hot glue,
and seal off the hole,
where the cord is running out.
[Music]
With the hot glue seal in place,
we can now put the light down
at the bottom of the bucket,
the pump on top of the light,
attach our pipe and faucet
on top of the pump,
and then start piling the stones in
because that's what's
going to hold everything in place.
Now, let's add some water.
How much water
you add is kind of up to you.
I like to bring it up to just
below the surface of the stones.
Random fact: A leaky faucet that drips
at the rate of one drip per second
can waste more than
3000 gallons a year,
which is equal to like 180 showers.
Okay, we've got our bucket plugged in.
Let's turn it on and see how this goes.
Now, ideally, the water will come up
out the holes in the top of the pipes,
and distribute themselves
around the sides.
Sometimes I've found that the water
kind of doesn't stick very well
to the pipe, and you kind of
need to just touch it to get
it start flowing everywhere.
Let's see what we can get.
Ooh!
Didn't need much encouragement at all.
Perfect. That means we did a pretty
good job of lining everything up,
so the water is being distributed
evenly all around, and look at this!
We've now got water
flowing out of the faucet,
and that's what's holding
the faucet up in the first place.
That's...
It's a really cool like, just illusion,
and makes it look like, Oh,
the waters holding the spigot up.
Very fun to look at.
[Music]
One of the main reasons I like using
these glass stones is that the signal
from my remote control has
an easier time getting down
into the bucket, so I can turn it on.
Now, it's really hard to
see in this bright daylight.
Let's take it somewhere
a little bit more visible.
[Music]
One more small modification
we can make is to take some very fine
grit sandpaper, and lightly, gently
sand of the tube from top to bottom.
This should leave some very
light white marks on the outside,
which can help enhance
the illusion of flowing water.
[Music]
It's not a major difference,
but you may decide
you like that look a little bit better.
Once again, I'm sure
I'm saying this wrong,
but Menachem Roubini,
thank you for your suggestion.
This is a fun build,
a fun project,
and it's definitely something
that you can do at home.
It doesn't take too long,
and it doesn't cost that much.
Check the links in the description
for where to buy
some of these pieces online.
Mr. Roubini, check your YouTube inbox.
We're going to be sending you 25 bucks.
Guys, remember, if you've got any cool
ideas of things you want to see us do,
let us know down in the comments,
and if we use your idea to
make a video, we'll send you $25.
Hmm...
Hose water.
Guys, it is subscriber
appreciation giveaway time.
We've got this cool
King of Random snapback hat,
and we're going to be
giving it away to one lucky fan.
All you have to do to enter is
first, be subscribed to the channel,
and second, make a post on Instagram
showing a picture or a video
of a King of Random project
that you have done, and tag us
with #TheKingofRandom.
We'll go through the posts on Instagram,
and choose a winner to receive this hat.
We're going to be doing more
of these giveaways going forward,
so keep watching for more
chances to win cool stuff.
We'll have hats,
we'll have cool merch,
and we may have
some larger ticket items,
hopefully, some cool
electronics, games, cameras?
We'll see.
Guys, that's not the end,
we've got more for you to see.
The box up up at the top will
transport you directly to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The box at the bottom will
show you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next,
and if you are not
a subscriber to our Channel yet,
hit the bomb in the middle to become one.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.